♪ ♪ ♪
- Avec la force et la conviction
du maestro Yannick Nézet-Séguin,
l'Orchestre métropolitain
de Montréal célèbre ses 40 ans.
YANNICK NÉZET-SÉGUIN,
directeur artistique de l'OM
- Quarante ans, c'est la pleine
maturité, mais c'est encore
plein de projets, c'est en plein
mon âge. J'ai 46 ans, donc
on se suit, comme ça fait 21 ans
que je suis à l'OM.
- Depuis 1981, l'Orchestre
métropolitain a fait des pas
de géants. Son succès ici comme
à l'international est lié
à celui de Yannick Nézet-Séguin.
Pour le concert d'ouverture de
la saison 2021-22, misera
sur du Ravel et sur une nouvelle
oeuvre d'une compositrice
Anishinaabe, visiblement
émue d'avoir été invitée.
- J'ai très hâte à ce soir.
Le pont entre les cultures,
ça a toujours été ça, ma grande
passion et c'est ça
qu'on véhicule à l'OM.
- Le temps passe et les succès
s'accumulent pour
Yannick Nézet-Séguin.
Cette semaine, à New York,
pour la toute première
fois dans l'histoire
du Metropolitan Opéra,
il a présenté une oeuvre
d'un artiste afro-américain.
- Ce compositeur, Terence
Blanchard, un grand compositeur
jazz, de musique de films,
a fait un chef-d'oeuvre, c'était
plein de gens issus de
la diversité.
Pour moi, c'est ça,
l'avenir de l'opéra
et ce n'est que le début. Il y
en a plein de projet
dans la tête.
- Le pouce en l'air,
le maestro a beaucoup de pain
sur la planche.
Après Montréal, il sera
au Carnegie Hall avec
l'Orchestre de Philadelphie.
Le chef-d'orchestre applaudit
la réouverture des salles.
- C'est sûr que c'est beaucoup
de voyages, beaucoup de musique
d'un coup, mais c'est sût que
c'est la fête totale parce que
c'est non seulement de retrouver
l'énergie du public, mais
au Met, à Philadelphie comme
à l'OM, notre priorité, c'est
de pas revenir comme avant.
- Ici Louis-Philippe Ouimet,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.